[Musique]
pouvoir voyager autres partis pour
former nos salles et aux agents de
ghislain de cesser de travailler linda
coeur de remplir une de ses enfants
les rebelles ou vriet s'accorde à une
pause il s'installa à l'ombre d'un chêne
et sans songer d'une époque futurs ou
toute idée de son travail sera formé
dans cette histoire de remplir et
février saint quentin
[Musique]
le co leader est bloqué sous cet amas de
tôle le visage est creusé tout près de
mon épaule le compteur est bloqué et eu
manque à l'appel
quand le lac gelé
c'est lui qui nous appellent c'est lui
qui nous redire tous les secrets du
siècle cette mémoire enfouie mais qui
reste fidèle tout lé monde du silence
les paroles d'oublier ce sont les
intenses
ce sont des vies cachées
[Musique]
la langue je me temime dans le palais
des ondes autour des tours de briques
dans le soleil sombre la machine
s'emballe les appétits s'aiguisent plus
de force animale plus de bras de chemise
c'est la révolution sur les chemins de
fer les compteurs en fusion les uns
délétère c'est la révolution du nil une
éphémère que je cherche le nom du
nouveau millénaire
[Musique]
qui
le conteur je l'accuse sous cet amas de
tôle
[Musique]
pour
georges bloqué petit manque à l'appel
dans le large que gelée
celui tout apple
c'est lui toujours gai tous les secrets
du siècle c'était mémoire enfouie
ces deux
tout le monde si j'analyse les paroles
oubliées
ce sont mes 20 ans
ce soleil
gachet
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
technique dans le palais raison autour
des tours de briques par le soleil et
son
machine s'emballe les appétits
s'aiguisent et de fox animal
plus de bras de chemise
l'évolution
les chemins de
les compteurs en riant
vettel c'est l'heure
du nul effet
et je cherche le nom
deux nouveaux hommes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir la chanson qu'on vient de jouer
s'appelle le nouveau millénaire
c'est une chanson qui est issue d'une
création que j'ai faite en juillet
dernier sur un site industriel à côté de
rennes pas très loin avec ce projet j'ai
travaillé avec des élèves de 4e sur la
révolution industrielle et sur la
mémoire ouvrière on est allé à la
rencontre de ces femmes et de ces hommes
qui ont travaillé il ya plus d'un siècle
sur le site et on essayait de de
restaurer de retravailler sur cette
mémoire qui attendent souvent à
s'effacer
voilà je suis comme disait karl tout à
l'heure je suis artiste et professeur
d'histoire géographie
il ya quelques années
enfin j'ai toujours séparés mais mes
deux métiers complètement et en 2008
lors d'un spectacle au festival des
tombées de la nuit à rennes on m'a
proposé d'associer quelques-uns de mes
élèves et je me suis rendu compte que
bah en fait mais deux métiers se
nourrissaient complètement ça m'ouvre
est énormément d'horizon avec tous ces
projets des passerelles se sont créés
entre les élèves les territoires et la
mémoire les trois chansons qu'on va
jouer ce soir ont toutes une histoire
qui est lié à un projet avec des élèves
il ya quelques années j'ai écrit une
chanson qui s'appelait les retours de
l'école un soir après avoir vu un film
de françois truffaut les 400 coups j'ai
pris une heure comme ça pour écrire une
petite chanson qui dure une minute
trente
je pensais pas qu'il emmènerait dans 9
pays à la rencontre d'élèves
au vietnam en chine au canada les
retours de l'école c'est le premier
moment de liberté dans l'enfance où il
n'ya pas l'autorité des parents il n'ya
pas l'autorité de l'école et c'est pour
moi un moment de poésie très fort et
avec mes complices on est parti dans ces
différents pays
on a fait des ateliers on a fait des
concerts et les élèves nous ont parlé de
leur retour d'école et ça a été une
porte d'entrée pour pouvoir connaître un
peu plus leur culture et même accéder à
plusieurs générations
en chine par exemple des élèves chinois
nous ont fait des interviews de leurs
parents leurs grands parents sur le
retour d'école nous parler de la
révolution culturelle et tout c'est tout
ce qui nous ont amenés en son et en
image en poésie mes élèves de à rennes
ont alimenté un blog pendant quatre ans
et ont fait vivre toutes ces histoires
[Musique]
non
vous
et
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais
[Musique]
nous
et retour de l'école à la tombée du jour
l'hiver sous les lucioles tout près du
quartier et retour de l'école dans les
rues aux barbes et les sirènes ne
s'affole et je traîne les pieds sous le
tissu froissé dans les corridors sont
je nous écorché les souvenirs dans le
petit mot d'amour dans les poches
cousues
c'est s'envole
c'est le fruit défendu
[Musique]
et retour de l'école les fins d'après
midi ils se mêlent se décollent les
pieds mouillés de pluie et retour en
arrière le long des astres clair dans
les quartiers sans bruit l'orage est un
mystère
[Musique]
le
maisons et des curieux se réveille du
musée
bonjour entré chez moi
quand je m'entraîne
[Musique]
et
m
le
q
[Musique]
et puis lors de ses quatre années de
voyage
on a traversé de nombreuses villes
l'inspiration préférant un nouveau
disque et
vient de sortir qui s'appelle accueil
transit
il parle de toutes ces villes qui sont
accueillantes et dans lesquels on on
reste pas toujours
[Musique]
des lycéens cette fois ci
on a retravaillé sur cet accueil
transiter ville imaginaire
et aussi ses villes
qui sont souvent à l'envers
qui sont les antiquaires postale
[Musique]
ils transitent
dans la ville fantôme
mais on
dans la brume
le train grasset
ak ville transit c'est
un dj
le trouvère
étrange accueil d'oiseaux vrombissant
[Musique]
comme une fêlure sur les âmes sensibles
blessés
une naissance à mort
connais pas
[Musique]
comines effet les
sur les cordages il
dans le bas
tu soldes
[Musique]
dans les alpes
divan
[Musique]
de larmes de sites
une alarme d
le cos terry
mais cela ce
[Musique]
accueil
bush
ville fantôme
point de passage néant
dans la cour une
[Musique]
accueil
toutefois indiqué
le trou béant
étrange atterri d'oiseaux en dix ans
[Musique]
le transit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
armelle talarmin providentiel
[Musique]
david manceaux au simple clavier
et tous derrière on ne voit pas
stéphanie grammond et d'image
[Musique]